as I've said many times before if there
are no cultists there really is no cult
it's just a guy screaming things that
don't make sense and nobody's paying
attention and the united in the United
States right now the level of
cultishness that has pervaded the
American right wing is getting to such a
degree that even cult isn't appropriate
because Cults are usually kind of small
and unfortunately a big part of the
modern Republican party has been taken
over by anti-empirical
anti-science in some cases paranoid
delusions that we would ordinarily say
if they replaced god with some other
word or they replaced a republican with
some other random person we would say oh
you need help you're in a cult we need
to get you out and we're going to look
at some examples of that right now this
is very interesting we've spoken before
about this group lacks for Trump
and one of the questions we had about
the group was does the group really
exist because they have almost no online
presence other than one very strange
website and blacks for Trump is a group
that often would show up at Trump
rallies and on the stage you would see
like over Trump's shoulder there would
be like a strategically placed blacks
for Trump person with the shirt and
everything often they would be gone
before the end of the speech well at
Trump's rally in Delaware Ohio over the
weekend right side broadcasting actually
interviewed one of these people from
blacks for Trump and it's completely
unintelligible the guy is like really
close to the interviewer and keeps
touching him everything about this is
bizarre but finally we have actual an
interview with one of these members of
blacks for Trump check this out
a person that comes to your aid helps
you all the time and then when you
really wants to come to your Aid
suddenly he's a racist when he was the
first one to say that black people
matter to him he said it directly to me
I'm sorry about that
he said it directly to me and and
um I forgot not Joseph Edison but uh
Miami Nights but he's done so much for
the for the black community and and sir
he did so much before the black
community right so there is blacks for
Trump making a point about something of
just a very strange situation then we
move on to a woman at the Trump rally
who explains that she believes Princess
Diana and Jackie Onassis are still alive
and tries to pull the interviewer into
it it is um I mean listen it's I I know
we always say well Dave is it we can't
diagnose but something is very wrong
with these folks okay first of all are
so cute I love the outfits I would like
detailed explanations on every single
shirt Ready set go right so living
living and we know living rule in the
world and you don't take down Evil by
being quiet or silent right so people
need to understand who they are do they
look like them today no do you think you
think Princess Diana is still alive
absolutely 100 do you I didn't but maybe
maybe you have something to that you
know that I don't know well you know God
speaks to us right right there's ways
that they can agree on you can figure
these things out so if people start
learning
abc123 which Michael Jackson talked
about how many years ago right and he
sang about so when people start
understanding Gematria they start
understanding the numbers a equals one b
equals two C equals three yeah pretty
open and shut case now if you're
wondering what Gematria is Gematria is
is Hebrew numerology using the the
Hebrew alphabet or as it's known the
aleph BET
um where you just you're basically it's
like what you did as a kid when you make
a code and you I'm going to write you a
note and like a is going to be one and D
will be four and that type of thing it's
just it's it's Hebrew numerology and in
my experience now I don't wanna I'm sure
there are Scholars somewhere that would
be exceptions to this I have never in my
life heard anyone use the word Gematria
or Gematria seriously
and they weren't completely out of their
minds maybe there's a counter example
but I'm certainly not uh not aware of
one here's a woman complaining about
critical race Theory
obviously she doesn't know what it is
like forget that ship has sailed it's
not even reasonable to expect them to
know what it is at this point she
doesn't know what it is but it sounds
like she says her kids go to private
school where like they don't even teach
whatever she thinks of as critical race
Theory it's really weird but she's very
upset private school
private so I was gonna say as a parent
what's your thoughts on what's going on
or the indoctrination of our kids with
some of their CRT and some of the other
really radical things
Ripple I mean
she's really stressed I mean her kids go
to a private school so it's not a
problem but it's really stressful but
they're trying to teach kids these days
it's just not right you know if it's if
it goes against God's word then it's
wrong
it should be as simple as that yeah now
of course there is separation of church
and state and public schools and so
really God's word should have no role to
play whatsoever but very very angry
people about things which they don't
understand and they don't and they
aren't affected by
uh but there it is here's a woman at the
Trump rally who said she had 10 Trump
flags on her on her porch and the host
volunteers that it's Un-American not to
have
Flags Okay yeah we've talked to them
earlier about hanging Flags let me ask
you a question in your neighborhood that
you guys live in your work whatever
Trump's flag still flying oh absolutely
oh yeah
you haven't seen my front yard it never
went down
my porch this is literal cultishness
this is you were you were signaling your
devotion you're signaling your devotion
in some Cults right the way you signal
your devotion is the leader gets to have
sex with whoever they want right so you
look at the Jim Jones cult you look at
the Charles Manson called that was a big
thing you signal your devotion by it was
a bunch of stuff you don't question what
the leader tells you and you're
available to the leader for sex whenever
hear the way they signal their devotion
is we never took down our flags
we kept the Trump flags up the entire
time we
and we right we
have promo for mypillow.com and my
store.com because I said if you have if
you don't have a flag in front of your
house hang on a second you know what
you're saying I'm Un-American right put
a flag in your front yard you have to
they demand compliance you must have the
signal that you are a member of the team
here's one guy who says that Trump
rallies are better than Grateful Dead
shows I tell all my friends I've seen
Jerry Garcia 129 times in concert it's
better than any Grateful Dead show and
it smells a lot better
go charm yeah so listen these folks at
least in theory they could be your kids
orthodontist they could be your kid's
teacher they might be the person fixing
your car or whatever right these these
folks really are everywhere uh and I
don't know how we deprogram them one
last bonus clip the there are opening
prayers at these Trump events and the
prayers are getting more and more
cult-like they're praying in thanks for
Trump for life and and we we're grateful
for the living Legacy of President
Donald John Trump we thank you for his
willingness to continue to organize and
to travel across our nation delivering
the message of freedom and to remind us
you and me that we play a critical part
in saving our nation we thank you oh God
for the clarity of purpose you have
given to president Trump so I think you
get it um Jamie Raskin member of
Congress he says he has started reading
about cults and Consulting cult experts
just for help on how to communicate with
his Republican colleagues in the House
of Representatives that's how bad it has
gotten and I don't know how we teach our
way out of it I don't know how we
educate our way out of it I I really
don't it's as depressing as I could
possibly imagine one of our sponsors is
blinkist who's been supporting the David
packman show longer than any other
sponsor blinkist is the app that lets
you listen to or read an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist is the way to absorb those
books you can't make time for blinkist
takes top non-fiction titles pulls out
the book's key takeaways and insights
and gives it to you in the form of
attack text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app I just
listened to this is your mind on Plants
by the great Michael pollen super
interesting the history of caffeine and
so many other things blinkist has you
covered on podcast too blinkist takes
long episodes of popular podcasts and
distills them into audio you can listen
to in 15 minutes with blinkist you can
become knowledgeable about so many
different things you can have
conversations with people about more
topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blink is for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com Pacman the link is down
below